this is Bergen sunny  now they're beyond the sunset lies the  home of the Dragon  I believe is your destiny to one day  find this hidden world so the people and  Dragons will fight no more  I think you think you know a lot about  dragons let me show you some what you  don't know have to give me a chance to  explain just let me show you could've  sworn you have teeth  [Music]  okay I've hunted every Night Fury except  yours and him over I will never get em  up  then I will destroy everything you love  [Music]  appear completely off  we have to fight for their freedom  your father  that's it  the strongest of the  you have the heart of its youth the soul  of a dragon only you can bring our  worlds together  [Music]  I'm proud to call you my son  [Music]  you are my best friend but  almost everybody over there  [Applause]  there were Jenkins when I was a boy  where they went only a few know our  story changed the world forever  [Music]